oui
françois gazinière son parti et de
monsieur du snob à repeindre sa maison
aussi je m'ennuie
je voudrais que tu viens de me voir
ah bon tu ne peux pas avant
bon et bien tant pis
dépêche toi ah oui oui d'accord j'ouvre
la trappe à tout à l'heure
bonjour c'est bien vous tombait mal
casimir est françois son parti léonard
ne peut venir que dans une heure ou deux
je suis tout seul
enfin je vais toujours ouvrir la trappe
vous savez la trappe du tunnel que
léonard a creusé de la malle de casimir
amigos
voilà
ah si je savais peindre aussi bien vous
à l'estival notre île
[Musique]
à
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup tout ça
vous rêvez
m
[Musique]
qui va me fuit les garçons
casimir chantant sa chanson
besoin
une vosgienne facile
[Musique]
je leur ai mis au pas la cgt
mais je l'aurais mieux peu si j'étais
vraiment
non
[Musique]
là
le
non
dans le kiosque des poupées
on est
leur serine titre onfray est grand a
[Musique]
là un papillon pas sur le banc
assis sur un banc géo
à regarder
mutine et les abats
[Musique]
on
mais je n'aurais même pas si je peux
[Musique]
je jouerai mieux peu si j'étais à menton
non
ça
[Musique]
à
ah merci merci à julie c'est vraiment
sympathique tu sais que j'aime beaucoup
cette chanson tu me quittes venir te
voir tu fais exprès de la chanter à
toute vitesse avant mon arrivée enfin
léonard tu m'a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas
venir avant une heure ou deux pas
d'excusés d'abord tu aurais dû deviner
je t'ai dis ça pour te faire la surprise
de venir aussi tôt ensuite il est arrivé
vraiment dans une heure je n'aurais même
pas entendu la fin de la chanson
il n'y a pas deux mais j'en ai ainsi
personne ne me change de chansons à moi
je retourne dans ma malle adieu le
voyons léonard yamaha
quel mauvais caractère ce renard
s'il veut des chansons il va en avoir
des chansons
[Musique]
à
dis-moi dimanche dimanche
dimanche le dimanche
dimanche
charente fait de la compote
bertrand sus des ans
cunego se teint en blonde et et
et
et pavillons das ses godasses
thérèse
son flow sur la braise les ont peints
des potirons
brigitte président s'agite site
s'inquiète
adema 8 10
il en a marre
la pendule fabrique des virgules
et moi dans touch un
émoi dans touch un
mois des blues pas sur ma langue
v le chat
à cergy on avait appelé le voile mfédé
répond toujours à l'appel des familles
en détresse que vous arrive t-il mais ne
soyez pas inquiète et le mec je vais
très bien non c'est pour léonard que je
vous ai fait venir aux tirs aux
signalements void est si mignon si
attendrissant mais que lui arrive-t-il
il est malade ou non il se porte comme
un charme seulement il m'a demandé de
vous parler ro aurait-il des reproches à
me faire à pauline sûr que non il
faudrait vous demander une faveur et ils
n'osent pas le faire lui-même on met aux
époux lui marcheur jules news et que
veut-il au ces petits papillons mauvais
c'est plutôt un renard jaune
raison de changer mais enfin mais que
vaut-il a bien voilà il voudrait que
vous alliez les chanter quelques heures
au
décidément ce renard les merveilleux ans
déjà l'idée de me choisir pour lui
chanter des airs un prouva goût exquis
et en plus cette façon de me le demander
et bien si je lui chanter quelque chose
comme par exemple une berceuse dont on
l'a enfin bon c'est très joli mais il
n'aurait pas envie de s'endormir en vous
écoutant alors oui c'est juste mais je
pourrais lui chanter le tango de
l'amitié elle rien ne vaut des amis mais
écoutez moi qui vous le dit à
franchement parler je crois que ce cop
préfère léonard c'est les voix qui porte
les airs d'opéra où j'adore ça moi je
vis de me voir si belle en ce sens
c'est exactement le moulin à eau
dépêchez vous aimez vous attend que je
rentre chez moi pour me coiffer gecko
allo léonard c'est julie dubois léonard
ne soit plus fâché tu sais tu vas
pouvoir entendre d'ici dix minutes une
chanson ravissante dans sa malle
il faut que tout soit prêt pour arriver
à j'ai bien fait d'être ferme tout à
l'heure ce sont obligés de venir me
console est maintenant en sommes à de
merveilleux va me fredonner des chansons
douces
[Musique]
que j'aime les voix douce revanche je
déteste les gens qui crient en chantant
c'est ce que j'ai entendu de plus
terrible c'est elle mais futé quand elle
quand elle se mêle de chanter des airs
d'opéra
c'est franchement éprouvante remarquez
je ne veux pas dire que je n'aime pas
l'enfer non mais chanté par un de mes
futé cette épouvante
voilà sûrement julie qui arrive je m'en
sens 12
petits gâteaux nous allons passer une
après-midi
formidable non pas que leonard ou comme
il est mignon petit les arbres d'avoir
préparé le thé pour sa gentillesse mais
qui va déchanter plein de jerry zeba
terreur was the river me voir si belle
en ce miroir
je ris